Mariah Carey says her son Moroccan grew
up on the former first lady
they have strong personalities the pop
diva was a guest on Monday nights watch
what happens live with Andy Cohen and
during a game of all I want for
Christmas is who
Mariah revealed the incident went down
during the National Christmas tree
lighting ceremony at the White House in
December 2013 the rocky spit up on
Michelle Obama's dress she was like
thanks to you I'll never be able to wear
this just again Rocky oh thank you which
makes sense now why Michelle was missing
for most of the photos on stage more
never knows
we belong together singer later
fangirled over Meryl Streep and got
candid about how she allegedly stole the
Oscar winners seat during the 2018
Golden Globes oh my gosh that was so
mortified because she had spoken to me
when I did precious yeah and she was so
sweet and just so like I was like I
can't believe Meryl Streep is talking
about my performance and we were
unbelievable in that film thank you but
I it's Meryl Streep and so that when I
sat in her seat it was like I didn't do
that but she was like you can sit at any
time she was very fast there she Mariah
who recently dropped her fifteenth the
studio album caution also dished on her
favorite memory performing with the late
Aretha Franklin that was the only time
we performed together by that event yes
we we saw each other many times we spoke
with each other a lot yeah of times yes
like that
divas live was the only time that I was
to perform with her I was very
intimidated and didn't want to perform
with everybody else was like let me have
it and I'm not saying anything against
anybody else yes but I felt there was a
thing where it was like they wanted to
be able to say like they took her on I
was like I'll be with the background
singers okay that's the Queen of Soul
yes and Patti LaBelle actually told me
she was like honey you did the right
thing because if you would have
participated in that situation I would
have had to because she knew that that's
the Queen and that's what you do but
Aretha was so like just real like she
said to me Mariah they're playing games
and I'm not having the games so we won't
be rehearsing tonight and we didn't even
get to rehearse and it was a Reetha
Franklin and I was like I've just sing
with her with the Franklin live on TV
with no rehearsal we were Hurst in her
trailer
[Music]